it turns out nevada students are
struggling to understand math and
english language arts yeah the nevada
department of education releasing data
from the smarter balance assessments
showing those proficiency gaps kate
houston breaks down the numbers and
shares how students can get caught up
it's devastating honestly to know that
the students of nevada are performing at
such a low breed due to the pandemic 68
percent of students grades three to
eight participated in the assessment
overall only 41 percent are proficient
in english it's 26 percent in math
that's compared to 48 and 37 percent in
the previous year i see a lot of
foundational issues stephanie shapiro a
content tutor at cultivate academics has
noticed huge gaps in learning within
ccsd less than 40 percent of middle and
elementary students are proficient in
language arts in math it's less than 25
percent if you're not understanding that
foundational concept you're really at a
loss
and hurting as you're moving forward
shapiro says one-on-one tutoring can
help students get back up to speed for
those struggling with language arts she
recommends reading out loud every day
flash cards are a simple and convenient
option to help with math and other
subjects you can really see their
confidence growing and then in the
classroom they are performing typically
much better than where they were at
before kate houston 8 news now
the nevada department of education says
it will use more than one billion
dollars in federal relief funding to
address these academic and emotional
needs of students they plan to present
and discuss this data at the end of the
month